that was wrong one of the crazies I
think we need we need our honeymoon well
less than six months later and it's over
yeah Tana mojo and Jake Paul are taking
a step back from their high profile
whirlwind relationship I know shocking
right here's what went down on Thursday
Tana took to Instagram to announce the
news posting this pic of her in Paul's
nug 'old up with their pet puppy she
captioned the sweet shot quote okay I
don't really know how to do a we're
taking a break post and this is weird as
[ __ ] I'm happy to still be able to sit
with Jake and laugh as we do this but
for right now we both are taking a break
to focus on our own very crazy lives
Tanna added that she will always love
Jake and she's grateful she made a best
friend for life and found someone to do
life with when no one else understood
her okay I'm kind of sad now anyway
Tana joked about getting half of his
assets including his Lamborghini he
loved me but the two were apparently
never actually legally married so yeah
good luck with that really never driven
before I've driven like twice oh my god
gosh goodness and don't go making
assumptions about the cause of their
split people Tana explained there's
nothing salacious about their breakup
quote this is coming from a place of
nothing but love I love you jakey Jake's
response love you then Jake shared the
same pic on his own Instagram revealing
they wrote their breakup announcements
while laying side by side quote as Tana
and I sit next to each other writing
captions about taking a break we're
literally laughing at how crazy and
stupid the past couple months have been
and cracking jokes at how silly this all
seems Jake said he wouldn't change a
thing
adding quote we're best friends and
right now it's best for us to focus on
our lives and see what the future holds
we make life exciting for ya the news
comes just days after Tana shared a
super emotional 40 minute long video to
YouTube mentally
just feeling lowest I've ever felt Tana
got candid about how unhappy she's felt
since saying I do to Jake at their
over-the-top Las Vegas wedding ceremony
in July the second that Jake and I got
married I just feel like everything
changed the second he said I do to me he
kind of mentally was just like now what
but I think he mentally was also over it
I don't know and I don't blame him but
it left me like clinging you know like
trying to to make this work and while
she didn't shy away from talking about
the problems in the relationship she
said she was still with Jake I always
want to be close with Jake no matter
what I shared one of the craziest times
of my life with this person and we were
a team and he made me feel some of the
best feelings I've ever felt just as
like a person but also some of the worst
I will always have a bond with him that
I don't ever see myself having with
anyone else
eg caught up with Anna in December and
she opened up about her hopes for the
new year the only thing I want to leave
behind him in 2019 is anything that's
inauthentic to be real I think that it's
very easy to get caught up in the world
of press and maintaining an image and
maintaining this highlight reel that you
know the world expects we all do it on
our Instagram and all that kind of stuff
but 2020 for me is a really big year of
realness and authenticity
just like being Who I am I got to get
back to that you know well okay I can't
say I'm surprised that these two aren't
living happily ever after but I do love
how sweet they're being to each other as
they take this break right of course you
can count on Nietzsche to bring you all
the latest news on Tana and Jake so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]